gente muitíssimo bom dia boa tarde boa
noite pra vocês eu vi um pouco de longe
claramente eu sou carioca não vou
conseguir enganar enquanto eu falo aqui
pra vocês é e para mim é muito especial
estar aqui hoje por alguns motivos
diferentes
primeiro que eu amo palestrar eu acho
uma ferramenta incrível de divulgação de
conhecimento
segundo que não é qualquer palestra está
falando do ted utad programa das novas
plataformas online pelo menos que eu
busco conhecimento
então é o momento aqui está falando de
uma faculdade que pra mim tem um toque
especial porque eu fui expulso do
colégio larguei a faculdade então minha
carreira acadêmica não é muito boa então
tá falando aqui pra vocês válida alguma
coisa desse no tempo e empreendendo é
vamos lá pra quem não me conhece meu
nome é luiz quinderé
pra quem me conhece meu nome também a
luz que dará mais as pessoas me conhecem
como luz do brownie
eu perdi meu sobrenome ao longo dessa
trajetória empreendedora e eu comecei eu
fundei o blog do luís com 15 anos na
cozinha dos meus pais
hoje eu estou com 1 29 então são 14 anos
aí nessa nessa jornada empreendedora
hoje a gente tem duas fábricas quatro
lojas sendo que uma das lojas inaugura
dia 31 em são paulo na vila madalena
então quem estiver em são paulo por
favor venham nos visitar vai ter aulas
de graça no evento no dia 31 ea isso
chama as pessoas que eu sei a gente tem
quatro lojas próprias mil pontos de
venda alguns aqui em são bernardo não
conseguiu puxar mas já tem alguns pontos
aqui o nosso planejamento de crescimento
todo voltado pra cá é a 50 colaboradores
incríveis seis sócios maravilhosos que
vou falar um pouco mais pra frente que
são essenciais é para todos os tipos de
empreendedor porque ninguém faz nada
sozinho
eu fui eleito um dos 30 jovens mais
promissores do brasil pela revista
forbes ea e além do brownie eu tenho
outras empresas não têm indústria
carioca a eu fiz um programa de tv de
empreendedorismo chamado fora da caixa
não fará mais gols haiti que ainda passa
mas quem quiser assistir tem no nacional
e no mais globosat play em dois
episódios entrevista de 20
empreendedores a loop distribuidora o
fone de ouvido com o áudio ea empresa de
pão de queijo juca é alguém que o
empreendedor também sem contar o pessoal
para destronar
levantou o braço baixa cabral agora não
vai perguntar só então a gente vai falar
que tem outro empreendedor aí é vocês
vão entender mas as pessoas acham quando
eu falo isso que eu tenho essa
quantidade de empresas que em desde os
14 anos que foi expulso do colégio
as pessoas estavam muito deturpada da
realidade da minha vida isso é muito
normal já acostumei com isso mas eu
gostaria de trazer pra cá porque a vida
do empreendedor não é fácil é e ela
antigamente as pessoas empreendedoras o
vilão né
hoje em dia o empreendedor a capa de
revista aqui na frente palestrando eu
não sei como vai ser nos próximos dez
anos mas eu sou empreendedor não importa
esse povo amoroso no forno amoroso mas o
que eu sinto é que as pessoas acham que
empreendeu uma coisa que ela não é é e
no brasil especificamente é muito mais
difícil prender brasil uma guerra gente
70% das empresas no brasil o vencimento
de cinco anos e não é que os
empreendedores são ruins o mercado é
muito difícil no brasil há o governo não
tinha incentivo os órgãos públicos
muitas vezes parecem que querem mais
atrapalhar do que ajudar a carga
tributária é uma das maiores e têm no
mundo você tem pouco retorno né então é
porque empreender como eu falei eu fui
expulso do colégio tem uma colinha aqui
pra volta as pessoas que estavam num
estudo as pessoas querem empreender na
universidade é 60% dos alunos
universitários querem empreender e
porque eles querem empreender que eles
querem ganhar mais porque eles querem
trabalhar - e por que eles não querem
chefe
eles não entendem que todas as verdades
são mentiras porque conseguia ganhar
mais 70% das empresas na frente 65 anos
você perder dinheiro é muito maior
como é que quer trabalhar - ele falou
que trabalha 14 horas por dia desde os
14 anos 15 anos que nem a gente trabalha
muito mais que a pessoa que quer ter
assinado sua carteira assinada chegará
acabou delas e só depois vai para casa
eu trabalho sábado domingo feriado
ninguém vê
é então isso é tudo isso é tudo mentira
gente vocês querem prender por esses
motivos não empreendam você tem que
empreender propósito você vê na fala do
do trade que tem propósito envolvido ele
faz aquilo por amor ele faz pra mostrar
pra ninguém não faz isso por nada e eu
acho que esse é um dos motivos
principais
é impossível empreendendo possível então
muita gente é muito difícil no brasil eu
amo empreender minha mãe empreendedora e
eu gosto muito do assunto então leio
muito sobre o assunto eu converso muito
dos judeus today sobre isso apesar de um
tempo formado é e aí eu comecei a tentar
traçar um paralelo entre todas as
pessoas que eu admirava e são
empreendedores meus amigos enfim livros
que eu leio só que a realidade
empreendedor cada negócio a negócio
diferente então é muito difícil você
traçar um paralelo porque é muito
difícil muito diferente além de brown
news e dj são coisas totalmente
distintas
óbvio que a gente vai ter coisa ali que
vão se cruzar com ser muito parecidas
mas o grande um grande marco muito
difícil mas que características destes
empreendedores têm como os
empreendedores de sucesso entre aspas né
com sucesso o tempo que cada um defende
uma maneira diferente é mais que os
empreendedores de sucesso em comum ouvir
22 habilidades é que todos os
empreendedores tiveram não importa que é
o fracasso
então assim é e falaram isso aqui a
primeira parece o fracasso é muito
importante que a gente trata o fracasso
de uma maneira muito errada desde o
colégio e da faculdade você tira nota se
repete
você volta gente eu não quero falar mal
da faculdade eu to falando um pouquinho
mas realmente não é esse o objetivo
mas eu acho que desde pequeno a gente é
ensinado a não errar aqui errar está
errado e não é tipo e rafa as partes do
processo você aprende a partir do erro
então eu acho que é fundamental ea gente
sabe que o erro fundamental é essencial
para você conseguir crescer e fazer
coisas diferentes sair da sua zona de
conforto entender que a sensação de
conforto você vai errar mas depois vai
aprender você vai acertando a partir
dali eu acho que a segunda é clara entre
todos os empreendedores é determinação
então determinação é unânime em todos os
empreendedores assim na mas as pessoas
confundem determinação com excesso de
trabalho e eu acho que a fala do grammy
me tocou muito por conta disso porque
ele já ele já tem os dois alinhados na
imediata antes do show eu não tenho essa
consciência pesada da minha mãe sem ódio
eu era contra a minha mãe não queria
isso sabe
e aí há dois anos atrás
a empresa já faturam milhões com 50
pessoas com lojas e tam em eu estava
passando um dos piores momentos da minha
vida e as pessoas não têm noção disso
pessoas só vêem o bolinho sendo vendido
nas lojas tudo bonitinho todo
arrumadinho por n motivos primeiro a
crise do país há dois anos atrás do país
estavam nas piores crises da história e
é claro que uma empresa de ônibus
chocolate também vai ser afetada
aí eu fui afetado é a gente estava a
gente descobriu um roubo na nossa
empresa duas vezes em dois lugares
diferentes no estoque em uma das nossas
lojas de roupa de volumes significativos
é com a crise com roupa é claro está
perdendo dinheiro
e aí eu comecei a dever dinheiro também
não satisfeito com isso eo a cultura da
empresa nunca esteve tão mal na história
da empresa que é o que eu mais foco no
principal objetivo a última outro slide
aqui e aí para não confundir voltar à
equipe o slide é pra cuidar dos outros
ou de uma empresa que cuide de você
primeiro é uma coisa que eu não estava
fazendo e há dois anos atrás no meio do
natal que é porque mais trabalho que
tipo de obra no faturamento assim é uma
loucura de de trabalho realmente o turno
na fábrica tem uma rede lá que às vezes
de fato num eu caí com a dor de cabeça
assim muito muito muito forte que nunca
tinha sentido antes
aí peguei o carro para casa dos meus
pais aí no meio do caminho e quase que o
desmaio que tem um fusca estava um calor
no rio de janeiro que era viram né
dezembro
é a seguir na casa dos meus pais colo de
mãe né tentem melhorar não melhorei dia
seguinte foi o hospital farei minha mãe
não estou suportando de dormir leva o
hospital e pra falar isso nem eu estava
com muita dor mentor de hospital
hospital na última hipótese possível
e foi o que aconteceu nesse dia eu
cheguei no hospital de média gama
ficaram com meningite é que é uma doença
que tem diversos níveis e pra quem
conhece eu não conhecia até então só que
um dos níveis é a causa morte em
pouquíssimos dias 45 dias
quando ele me contou não sabia meu pai
trabalhava no painel vai começar a
chorar e se a nossa áfrica afirmou
não sei muito bem o que é mas é isso meu
namorado me olhou com uma cara de
assustado e sem fio vai ficar tudo bem
lá vai vai
só o médico né
e aí o cara é graças a deus não era uma
meningite do pior estágio eu tive que
ficar em pleno natal durante uma semana
no hospital mas duas semanas em casa e
sem poder saber o que estava acontecendo
porque o que tinha me levado aquela
situação era imunidade baixa era causado
pelo stress da meningite c não tem como
se prevenir de alguma maneira em que não
ficar estressado editar como bem esse
tipo de coisa que é que todo mundo sabe
fazer maioria das pessoas não fazem
então fiquei isso foi muito marcante
para mim porque três semanas no período
que eu mais tenho que trabalhar e que
mais precisa de mim no momento da
empresa que mais de mim e eu era
obrigado a não fazer nada
fui por um lado foi muito bom o time
tenta pensar e aí eu fiquei pensando em
porque que eu cheguei naquele lugar né e
pela primeira vez numa das primeiras
vezes na história da empresa assim eu
não tinha uma resposta
eu sei que a resposta não me prendem o
problema é que faz o que eu faço aqui
terceira parcial que chama o cara tá
nesse momento não sabia eu de fato não
sabia como contornar ea gente já era
relativamente grande nesta 1.200 mais
quadra relativamente grande mas o caso
do refúgio aqui na escola de fábrica e
tainã esse tipo de coisa é já é uma
estrutura mais robusta é vocês já são
faturamento saltos a gente já fala em
milhões de reais e é muito difícil ainda
mais o meio ambiente o colégio a r$3 é
como é que o muito essa situação toda a
etapa passou natal não sabe nem quanto
tinha vendido nem continha nada aí me
chamou pra conversar com os sócios
hoje eu tenho 76 sócios na comissão
somos sete sendo que quatro trabalham
comigo diariamente na operação
e eu fui conversar com ele sem saber o
que falar mas já com aquele pensamento
de buscar preciso o que falaria
você tem que tá mal se sente mal você
sendo líder tem que botar aquela cara
bonitona fingir que está tudo bem
entrando no carro depois do bate a
cabeça na parede só com vida mas pros
seus liderados você tem que passar uma
credibilidade do enem
então cheguei lá naquela posição é o
trabalho e sair doente só que eles eram
os sócios da mulherada estão estão do
meu lado né
de alguma maneira na hora que eu falar
de me pararam ou não
isso é não é isso a gente não criou
empresa por conta disso
isso aqui não vai acabar dessa maneira a
gente está aqui há 10 anos um contínuo
há dez anos só tinha 25 agora dez anos
depois tem mais cinco mais 45 aqui atrás
ea gente está aqui junto contigo isso
aqui vai ser só mais uma página do livro
que a gente vai escrever junto é eu não
funciona porque eu tinha pensado nem
empresa mesmos 11 15 anos um filho mesmo
assim de não saber o que fazer mas isso
eu sou branco playboy na classe a é
estudado apesar do estado no melhor
colégio tem nas melhores faculdades
enfim não era bom aluno me formei mas eu
tive que tem na europa
é eu sei que o senhor 0.01 50 da
população aí eu sou favorecido por
seether por ser um homem pelo discurso
do meu amigo do iphone que passou e
mesmo assim eu tava naquela situação
fique mais nas pessoas que não têm esse
privilégio que eu tenho que são alguns
dos meus sócios por sinal é e aquilo foi
muito marcante para mim e aquilo me
mostrou que para você ser um bom
empreendedor aqueles dois ativos que eu
tinha falado é de você acreditar no erro
entender que o erro faz parte e ter
determinação precisavam ser somados à
pessoas é que foi sempre o meu principal
motivo de estar a empresa é na verdade
eu eu amo pessoas o que eu mais gosto e
eu faço isso pelas pessoas né de fato
entre elas eu tô falando eu faço só por
ela eu acho que todas as pessoas
envolvidas
é isso aqui são parte delas tal só pra
vocês vocês olharem um pouco pra prédio
que olhava muito a forma porque o
produto leva o meu nome então nas
pessoas não vêem quem está por trás
disso
e esse aqui é o meu irmão é um dos meus
sócios que estava nessa conversa é a
vânia que eu vou falar um pouco mais pra
frente o paulo tem marido dela eo
espírito são os meus sócios que estavam
nessa fatídica conversa que que foi um
grande marco para mim em termos de de
empresa e eu consigo entender que que eu
de fato não estava sozinho porque o
empreendedor é um cara solitário ele é o
que é chamado de louco é o que fala você
nunca vamos fazer isso volta a estudar
para vender
chocolate então não só isso vai ser dj
vai ser dj história de j
o futebol tem uma escola mais cedo e
ficar apertando o botão num mais é agora
mas as pessoas falam vai ficar fazendo
boninho farinha com a sua moto fazer
bolinhas outra faria com açúcar e mexa e
outras que só enfeite acaba de entregar
se a pagar imposto de nada é só produzir
um negócio então é e aí eu queria falar
dessas pessoas especificamente é de
pessoas e de diversidade que foi falado
aqui também é vânia maria essa aqui é a
minha principal sócia principal é a
primeira só se ela era empregada na
minha casa como eu falei eu sou playboy
minha família tem dinheiro e havana
empregada na casa avalie a família toda
nordestina na família não tinha dinheiro
e amanhã empreendedor ela conseguir pra
gente mas a realidade de vida dela foi
muito diferente da minha e havana uma
das pessoas meninas trabalharam na minha
casa teve um do maranhão também da
função de minha mãe minha mãe meu pai
vieram ela tem 23 irmãos
vinte e três irmãos da dois times de
futebol e um juiz ainda dá
e veio veio para o rio de janeiro com 13
anos em busca de emprego é quando
trabalhava na casa estava com mais
quatro trabalhos mais quatro empregos e
as pessoas não vêem essas pessoas que
passam despercebidas pela maioria das
pessoas é o seu porteiro que sua
empregada entrou em fim o cara do
elevador que o frentista o motorista que
a gente não sabe a realidade daquelas
pessoas o quanto elas têm para se
agregar porque a gente foi conversando
só com gente que nem eu que teve um
padrão de vida que estudam nos mesmos
lugares que aprendi isto que tiveram os
mesmos livros é claro vão concordar
comigo a gente não nos lugares teve uma
criação o meio tt leva para um lugar
parecido nesta semana na mesma região da
pessoa eu aqui tem uma diferença
cultural muito grande você expõe outra
cidade tem coisa diferente eu tenho
praia você tem dinheiro né
tem divergência é em tão eles cara eles
me ensinaram muito a vânia apesar de um
quando conheci ela não era formada agora
ela se formou no colégio e quer fazer
uma faculdade é ela se achava inferior
às outras pessoas não ter feito uma
faculdade por não ter estudado isso é
uma coisa tão arrogante na nossa parte
isso é isso é tão comum na sociedade que
eu fico até triste é que só quem tem
conhecimento o cara tem diploma é eu
acho que eu não me forma muito por isso
também pra bater nessa tecla de tipo a é
verdade que eu podia ter informado podia
ter pesado curso à distância e qualquer
e tem informado mas eu acho que é legal
porque as pessoas mas quando tudo parece
as pessoas têm que parar e ouvir durante
os 40 minutos
é isso é muito legal porque você você
quebra muitos paradigmas de o cara de
sucesso não é o cara que estudou o tema
parece que eu dei pra lá direito na
universidade que o pai o pai um dos
alunos que era um cara mais velho ele
começou a chorar durante a palestra ele
falou luís é você fez ou mudar minha
relação com o filho porque o meu filho
pensa em você mas eu sou da antiga o
como é que o antigo economia oscilante
economia eu não consigo visualizar o
mundo da maneira que você visualiza e
meu filho risos é que nem você
então vou chegar em casa vou ter uma
conversa muito diferente que eu tive com
meu filho em toda minha vida pra isso me
deixou no lugar de cada tirada faz
sentido que eu estou fazendo aqui né
então é eu falo isso que a vânia ela me
ensinou muito mais do que muitos
professores meu sim há muitos só têm um
conhecimento de de vida muito diferente
no meu e muito complementar ensina
diariamente se formar no colégio tá indo
se formar na faculdade está virando uma
empresária de ponta hoje a nossa empresa
não seria arrumar essa não tivesse ela é
uma das três mais importantes que tinha
gente na zona de conforto traz a gente
um chão né a gente é muito interno e
principalmente a internet tudo
imediatista vamos lá a gente consegue
conhece muita gente não gente calma
calma não é assim que funciona e de fato
não é a minha realidade não na realidade
todas as pessoas eu não posso acreditar
que essa
a realidade vai ser ver a empresa porque
a empresa você não controla tudo o que
está acontecendo
paulo era o marido dela era não é o
marido dela coitada é é o marido dela
paulo também da paraíba também do
nordeste nela nenhuma da paraíba é ele é
um cara mais inteligente que eu já
conheci
é inteligente mesmo assim que pra mim
inteligência você tem um conhecimento
muito grande a respeito de um assunto
pra mim e inteligência é você saber
aprender e aí você consegue aprender
qualquer coisa pra mim esse cara é um
cara inteligente hoje encontrado pessoas
na empresa não pela capacidade técnica
daquela pessoa mas sim pela como ele vê
o aprendizado quando não sabe uma coisa
o que esse cara faz quando não sabe
alguma coisa ele fica parado esperando
alguém dá uma resposta ou e se levanta
no youtube está no google pergunta por
causa da frente vai no mecânico da
frente da escola está acontecendo então
o paulo é um desses caras
paulo hoje cuida da nossa produção tem a
maior equipe da empresa ele que gera uma
demora equipe da empresa ele conserta
nossas máquinas ele conserta o nosso
carro disse eu
e se eu pedi pra gente pra lua de jegue
ele dá um jeito tenho certeza já
abrigaram comigo por conta do tempo que
o filósofo frei mais do que deveria mas
só passando aqui meu irmão ele tem a
mesma formação que eu quero nenhuma
então também não informou mas é um
geniozinho ele complementa muito é um
gênio da matemática é um cara muito fora
de série
esse é o nosso único formado da empresa
a gente prometeu continuar fazendo
estágio quando geninho informado da
empresa é esse aqui é pós-graduado em
comunicação é formado pós-graduado então
ele é ele é o cara que cuida da
comunicação desde sempre o cara que
criou a nossa luta é o cara que fez fez
toda essa fez tudo que a gente fez ficar
bonito né
e eu queria falar uma frase em um
provérbio africano finalizar que eu
gosto muito
se quiserem rápido vá sozinho se quiser
ir longe vai o grupo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]